[Music]
[Applause]
he is the commissioner of the sec's Greg
Sankey joins us on the program how many
games did you go to in the last week
or
and uh week zero I was at Vandy so I'm
five games into my season already do you
tailgate
no I've uh there's a bit of a hazard for
me walking through tailgates most you
know people when when they're together
are actually really nice in person uh on
social media maybe not quite well you
know Commissioners always get booed do
you get do you get booed
oh that's happened a couple of times I I
was um I was at the the LSU national
championship celebration and smattering
but you know most people are really kind
and I reminded him it was the first year
that the conference had approved beer
sales in Tiger stadium which resulted in
a great a great positive Roar so you
just got to know how to play the game if
you're made how would you recap this
summer for college football oh wow
um I I will say this year you know July
4th weekend was quiet which is unlike
the last five years so we had the chance
to celebrate celebrate July 4th without
the cell the cell phone in in hand uh
but certainly a time of change I think
the the pressures that are there I saw I
saw Jack last week
um I expressed my disappointment I was
not on set in Dublin with you and Will
Ferrell but we'll do it by zoom and you
know he expressed a perspective
um I probably wouldn't describe it quite
with those same terms but it's a time of
change change the time of pressure
um a time that that has a level of
discomfort across college football and
really I think all of college sports uh
in case people what the commissioner is
referring to Jack swarbrick the athletic
director at Notre Dame had this to say
two weeks ago in Ireland
can you sum up what's happening with
college football in the last where would
you start complete disaster
how did it how did we get here Jack I
wish I knew and and listen I'm not uh
everybody in the industry has to take
responsibility here I'm not uh excluding
myself from that I think uh the
decision-making
has lost its way in terms of the focus
on the student athlete and what's
primarily best for them
um but we are where we are and we have
to try and make it work I mean we've
been pretty
uh vocal in the past month about we need
to find a home for Stanford and Cal that
you can't have two of the great academic
institutions in the world not have a not
have a place to play
how do you think Jack got to this uh
bottom line there well I I thought his
his follow-on comment was really
important the observations about uh
shared responsibility about decision
making
uh we all look at reality from our
perspectives in the Southeastern
conferences made decisions over the last
few years the addition of Oklahoma and
Texas for example that actually did
contemplate The student-athlete
Experience our ability to add 95 miles
to our geography but Elevate our
competitive experience bring in national
champions and and challenge ourselves uh
but you know we we've historically been
slow to adapt in college athletics
that's not new that's not like this
decades or this generation's issue we
now have a set of external pressures
that I think are part of Jack's
observation that create the discomfort
so we have state legislatures making
laws and dictating how we will run
athletic programs we have interest from
Congress I'm not I'm not clear that
there's a commitment to help restore a
National Standard we have change in the
NCAA I've appreciated Charlie Baker but
we're still dealing with a bureau
accuracy that is slow to adapt to Modern
realities and at the same time on our
campuses and in our conference office we
have to adapt to those modern realities
um every day so Dan I think that's a
combination of frustration you heard but
also uh the change that's inherent in
our society right now what concerns you
more name image and likeness or the
transfer portal
I would say the the the ecosystem if you
will or the environment that's developed
around name image and likeness going
back to 2018 2019 uh that label would
have been envisioned
um in a certain way and we have any
number of student athletes you think
about Bryce young and Dr Pepper ads and
Olivia Dunn and viori commercials I mean
that's what that's what it was we had
football lineman telling us about a car
wash deal that they have for all their
pickup trucks and that's normal activity
what's what's happened is it's become a
recruiting inducement it's allowed
outside influences boosters if you will
and now collectives that we've held off
from being involved in recruiting
they've entered this realm and I think
bottom line what that means is one we've
shifted control of our Athletics
programs away from campus leaders who do
have an accountability structure we also
have created questions of hey when I'm
student athlete from Team a lining up
against a competitor from Team B are we
actually playing by the same rules and
that's where we have to have the
restoration of a national Center that's
happened around this name image and
likeness space and it's developed in a
way that's not exactly what would have
been envisioned as I described four or
five years ago what's the craziest
amount of money you've heard that a
player is getting well I read the media
accounts and and I actually don't
believe what I read so you've seen
multiple multiple Millions
um I I I I question whether that's true
because people involved in in this nil
space third parties agents nil reps are
incentivized to inflate the number and
you asked about nil or transfer portal
so I had to pick one but what we have is
a layering of the issue so more transfer
Freedom which that's our reality
um but it's been layered with the
ability to now go out and inflate
numbers and so I think there has to be
care in believing the numbers that one
sees publicly he's the commissioner of
the SEC Greg Sankey um finish this
sentence if the SEC didn't bring in
Oklahoma and Texas
would have been a lot more pressure on
me the last few weeks
um a lot more questions and from my
perspective our decision in 21
has been shown to have been a really
wise decision and one of the cool things
just from the time we're talking is
Texas will be playing Alabama uh this
Saturday which is a a I think a sign or
an indication into our future and the
excitement around these competitions in
a 16-team sec but this sort of started
the game of musical chairs didn't it
Texas Oklahoma well I think you have to
go back to uh expansion in the early
2000s Dan I mean that's reality so the
Big East uh losing three members
initially to the ACC and then a member
to the Big Ten three more members to the
ACC it dissolved uh that seemed to be a
time very different than than what we
had experienced before when for instance
Arkansas and South Carolina joined or
pens joined the SEC or Penn State joined
the Big Ten you then had the pack 10 at
the time trying to grow to the pac-16
that created change a year later we went
from 12 to 14. so I don't think you can
go back to just the summer of 21
um the summer of 21 was different but
one of the questions my president's
asked me is we were considering the
growth is
um what does the Big 12 do so the Big 12
had opportunities to add members it went
is the Big 12 from 10 to 14 and then to
12 when Oklahoma moves
um what happened this summer is
different so the the decisions to go in
a very different Geographic Direction
some of that happened in 22. I'd submit
when you look over time those are a
little bit different but if people want
to point the finger at our expansion
I'll take that responsibility I will
just note and I think you and I've
probably discussed it uh way back in
2015 I offered some perspective star
presidents that was my first meeting as
commissioner that change was coming
around the 20 to 23 24 cycle when these
media agreements
um were renegotiated and that was pretty
prophetic
yeah I just wonder couldn't we keep the
football couldn't we keep the Pac-12
playing football against the Pac-12 why
why do we have to bring all the other
sports to these other conferences I I'm
trying to understand that the geography
so you don't have to disrupt the Pac-12
uh I've I've been asked that question a
couple of times my response is usually
I'm the least qualified one to answer
since when we expanded we had about 95
miles to our geography yeah
um I think it could have remained
um decisions made by campus decision
makers and Conference decision makers I
think there were public observations
dating back to the summer of 22 about
potential movement you have different
people and commissioner roles you have
different perspectives uh on Traditions
or traditional alignments that's what
seems to have provided these
opportunities are these opportunities
for change
um I think the Pac-12 could have resided
and and Dan embedded in the question is
a bit of the observation we've seen of
just let football operate on its own and
I've said and I'll say to you we operate
athletic departments football uh at
least at this point is not divorced from
everything else we do it may be it may
be different the stadiums are bigger
than the Arenas uh but for us we view
the connectedness that there are
relationships with our Athletics
departments that are healthy and you
know what in the Southeastern Conference
uh we've got huge football games we have
huge baseball games relative to the rest
of the world I think those reflect on
each other and build the intensity the
rivalries and the interests just like
basketball and and volleyball and
softball do and I don't want us to
sacrifice that for what becomes a
short-term solution lastly on this break
football out idea I don't know how you'd
ever tell a football player in you know
last year we had the first round draft
pick in the NFL draft first round in
Major League Baseball the first
Collegiate picked in the NBA draft and
the first draft pick in the WNBA I don't
know how you say to the football player
we can do a b and c for you but to the
basketball player men and women and the
baseball player even though you're going
to be a draft pick is going to make a
bunch of money we can't do these things
because you know we're stuck in this
other organization
college football needs a boss
right
well that's one way to ask the question
um do we all go back to the summer of 20
if we had all said somebody else is
going to make the decision for the
Southeastern Conference about whether we
play it in the fall of 20. I don't see
that working terribly well so it's a
it's a it's a simple observation with a
set of complexities yeah you're right
you're right but I I think look I'm a
traditionalist
um
like I I want these rivalries I I I want
to make sure that we have some kind of
fiscal sanity here not just everybody's
got to go and get get their money that
that's what concerns me you know
nobody's concerned about that that these
schools are leaving getting more money
but then the kids want to go and get
more money and then we have a bigger
problem with that it feels like than we
do hey game of musical chairs let's sit
down before there's no chairs left well
and and I'll go back to some of the
comments so
um we we aren't always consistent in our
messaging right so I I had coaches who
said wow you know people just move well
they have to wait so Oklahoma and Texas
we announced in 21 they had to wait
three years you know there's no student
athlete in the transfer portal who Waits
three years yeah now we complain about
three months now so from a philosophic
consistency I think some of these quick
sound bites aren't accurate to reality
for us I'm going to go back to the
conversations I had with the president
at Oklahoma and the president of Texas
it was we've watched how your
conferences function we've watched how
it's made decisions we watch how you led
we want to be a part of that I actually
think to your point if you put the money
in front of every other element of
decision making you don't make good
decisions in life whether that's
personally or professionally so for us
we looked at the right affiliations the
right geography the ability to restore
rivalries you think about Texas and
Texas A M playing again Oklahoma
Missouri were part of the big eight
Texas and Arkansas is a Legendary game
we do disrupt some things but we
actually restore more that's actually a
unique conference expansion template
relative to what's happening around us
yeah I got less problem with the SEC
than I do some of these you know other
conferences that you know no need to
mention names here so no I'll take that
as a complicated
you don't want me to call Jack swarbrick
and get his comments on the SEC well I
don't even know what he thinks do you
get along with all these Commissioners
with the other conferences anybody not
like you
um they're probably been moments if you
go back to uh the summer of 21 there
wasn't a lot of warmth in the room so
that was when we announced the
invitations to Oklahoma and Texas uh I
think there's been a thawing I'm I'm not
like the good guy right because I'm not
out there recruiting talking to uh Jack
and I get along great I actually uh I
value Jack's perspective and even well
we might disagree on elements of
terminology I I think being as direct as
Jack can be is is really beneficial so
yeah we we have views we have
differences we do have a responsibility
to collaborate Dan I think that that
actually informs your question about do
we need somebody to lead there there has
to be the ability for some of us to give
and some of us to take and those roles
to be reversed over time and uh I think
we've made a contribution in a potential
expansion of the expansion of the
college football playoff
um when it started we didn't want to
have that everybody else in the room had
needs
um and yet we compromised and I would
hope that we can continue to collaborate
even through all of these changes you
and Jack ever talk about Notre Dame
joining the SEC
no I I think he's got a healthy
affiliation you know we talk about the
future uh do you like how I threw that
in at the end
um I went up to when Georgia played just
to see a football game I was at Notre
Dame's game in Georgia uh but I respect
the the history that that Notre Dame has
in fact Dan I'm asked even in my own
conference meetings you know why Notre
Dame has their role in the cfp for
example and I said you know what I think
that's really healthy for college
football you you yourself talked about
traditions and uh even though we're in a
time of change and we've been a part of
that change we can still honor a number
of traditions and so Jack and I have had
that conversation certainly
good to talk to you hope you have a
second I hope you have a great day what
is the rest of the day
give us any Forex uh for example for
instance yeah I have there's a video
conference with the NCAA president uh
next uh we have our track and field
coaches who produce Olympians and
national champions uh and for a meeting
I'm preparing for a baseball coaches
meeting where we won the last four
national championships and never miss an
opportunity at the hype our presidents
and chancellors have a video conference
today as we we look at some of the
difficult issues present College
athletics
um there are two more things on my
agenda a couple of calls with ads
checked in with my officiating
coordinator we just finished a staff
meeting
um phone call first phone call this
morning was 7 30. so the days Move Along
it's all downhill after this interview
you know that yeah it is I just want to
be on the Dublin invite okay next year
Florida state is going to be playing
Georgia Tech
yeah I probably don't need to be it now
all of a sudden Florida State rumors uh
start to percolate and you're over there
in Dublin but yeah there's an open
invitation okay well that that's a good
uh reverse there on me you got me thank
you Jack
all right I'm sorry Craig I'm still on
Jack swarbrick yeah no I like my good my
good buddy from uh Dublin Jack swervin
uh thank you Greg we appreciate your
time as always absolutely good to see
you that's the commissioner of the SEC